well new footage released this lunch
time shows a queen being briefed on the
contests of her read by of her red box
by sir edward young who's been her
private circuitry since 2017.
um and it's very nice it's just a report
of
uh the ceremony for
for this award the women of leadership
award which uh happened in december and
it's but very nice you'll see ma'am
there's some
extremely extremely nice comments
including one from president biden
oh that's very kind isn't it
and this is this is the
yes this is the program
sky's royal correspondence ryan mills is
in sandringham for us now rihanna in a
truly historic day with some surprises
thrown in there as well the endorsement
of camilla certainly gives us an insight
into the future of the institution
oh it's certainly been a couple of days
of the unexpected
yes that accession day message last
night i think took everyone by surprise
but also these rare new pictures that
we've had of the queen it's important to
point out that it's very unusual for a
camera to be invited to film the queen
working away behind the scenes and it
really reminded me of how much before
christmas when the queen was unwell we
were being told that she was still
carrying on with light duties and a lot
of that would have revolved around
looking through those red boxes full of
papers so now we can see for ourselves
how the 95 year old monarch is briefed
every day by her private secretary
edward young on this occasion who has
been her private secretary since 2017
and you can see him talking her through
various things for example at the order
of who she was going to meet at the
event we saw her out yesterday at the
sandringham ballroom also talking to her
about a program from an event where she
was awarded a women of leadership
award in america saying that there was
also a message from from joe biden who
of course she's met on a couple of
occasions over the last 12 months so
yeah i think wonderful to see her
working way behind the scenes but it's
also the message that those pictures are
trying to deliver and it's one that the
queen is very much still committed to
her public service and duty yes there
was that message last night where she
talked about her successor being prince
charles but there is no sense of an idea
of abdication that simply is not on the
table and that is why we now have those
pictures of her working very hard we've
also had that statement from prince
charles as well acknowledging how much
it means to him
and camilla
that the queen has now turned round and
said that she believes that camilla
should be queen consort in a statement
that we've had in the last hour the
prince of wales has said that we are
deeply conscious of the honor
represented by my mother's wish as we've
sought together to serve and support her
majesty and the people of our
communities my darling wife has been my
own steadfast support throughout so
again there a very rare touching tribute
from the prince of wales to his wife i
think for a very long time he has wanted
her to be his queen consort in the
future now those very powerful words
from his mother can leave people in no
doubt about what the queen herself wants
to see